well hello everyone um and welcome to
the latest edition of sear talks my name
is Hannah yakabe and I'm the vice
president of communications at sear I'll
be your host for today as many of you
know cifar is a global research
organization that is proudly based in
Canada we convene extraordinary
researchers to address the most
important and pressing issues facing
science and Humanity today at cfar we
believe in the power of diverse
interdisciplinary communities of inquiry
our community of researchers
collaborates on Bold ideas in order to
share new and fundamental knowledge with
the rest of the world and that's
precisely what our sear talk series is
all about today we've just three days
left until cop 28 our discussion will
focus on a profoundly timely and
important topic climate
change you'll hear from researchers who
through working in diverse Fields share
the common goal of making an impact on
environment
before we officially begin the event I'd
like to share some logistical items with
you uh please note that today's session
will be an hour long there will be an
opportunity to pose your own questions
at the end you can do so by using the
Q&A function at the bottom of your
screen please submit your questions
there and we will do our best to address
them and please note that this session
is being recorded and will be available
on our website at c.ca in the next week
and now it's my absolute pleasure to
welcome our moderator for today Sear's
president and CEO Steven tup as many of
you know prior to joining sear Steven
served as the 346 Vice Chancellor at the
University of Cambridge where he was
also the first non-uk national to hold
the post prior to that he was also the
director of the monk School of global
Affairs at the University of Toronto the
president at the University of British
Columbia and the dean of law at McGill
University and of note for a discussion
today Stephen has just offered his
latest book which is titled build a rule
of law for a New Age of Anxiety and
which from his lens as a legal scholar
offers up a possible solution for
dealing with global issues like climate
change welcome Stephen over to
you well thanks very much Hannah it's
wonderful to join all of you and I'm
delighted to be moderating today's CFR
talk nurturing a resilient Earth as
Hannah mentioned the discussion isn't
just timely it's also deeply important
we've surpassed the inflection point on
climate change of course we await the
results of cop 28 beginning in just a
few days time but in the meantime today
we're in for a provocative discussion
you know that there's no Silver Bullet
that can stop climate change however
research innovation in this area could
still have profoundly positive impact on
our planet and that will be the Crux of
our conversation today so let me briefly
introduce our panelists welcome first to
Jackie gordal in Canada who examines how
microbial life persists within extreme
subsurface environments such as
permafrost oceanic crust and Marine
sediments we're also joined by Sarah gur
in the United Kingdom whose interest is
in plant disease with particular
emphasis on fungal infestations and
their Global
movement hello as well to David rol also
based in Canada and who studies ma
machine learning Innovation for tackling
climate change finally I'd like to
welcome Richard Taylor from the UK but
currently in California whose work
examines the impact of climate change
including the amplification of climate
extremes on groundwater systems so
welcome to all of
you well as we've already heard and we
know from so many conversations uh
climate climate change is one of the
most pressing issues of our time if not
the most pressing issue what role do you
think research organizations such as
sear can play in addressing climate
change Sarah why did I start with
you well good afternoon everyone from
the UK so for me it's an absolute
delight and an honor to be part of sear
because it seems to draw together the
brightest Minds within a given subject
from across the globe and as we tackle
problems with climate change as being
one of the most pressing pressing issues
of our time the unit that I'm involved
in is the fungal Kingdom and what we can
see is that fungi are moving in coner
with climate change and they're
profoundly affecting our calorie crops
they're also causing diseases and So
within the Consortium in the fungal
Kingdom suddenly there's this idea that
we can all speak out of the box and the
ideas that we come up with are truly
inter disciplinary within the fungal
Kingdom and we can invite other people
and be
transdisciplinary so this is a huge
honor to be part of the sea which makes
a very significant contribution to the
area of climate change
studies thanks Sarah maybe I'll come to
you Richard I I'm I'm curious from your
perspective what do you think research
brings to bear on climate change and and
and research organizations what
difference can we
make well one of the key things what and
one of the things I find with research
organizations and and for instance
specifically with
sefar um is that it enables us to pursue
curiosity driven research and that that
is hugely important it's it often
between and even across disciplines and
for me I think this as an immensely
important role as allows for Innovation
and we really require this if we're
going to be tackling some of these major
challenges around climate change
and it does this in a way that for
instance conventional sources of funding
certainly those from research councils
that I'm work with in the UK are less
able to do so it's a really it's it's an
important Niche area that cfar does in
enabling this interdisciplinary work but
also Cur curiosity driven
work thanks very much I'd like to now
move to some of the advances that are
actually taking place in the fields that
you collectively work in uh that relate
to climate change Jackie let's begin
with you what's actually happening out
there yeah I mean one one Advance that's
really so I'm an environmental
microbiologist and I look a lot at the
Ecology of microorganisms in various
environments including permafrost
systems permafrost has a lot of carbon
and microorganisms are the mediators of
that carbon uh one recent relatively
recent advances is just realizing that
microorganisms May mitigating more
greenhouse gases than we previously
thought uh for example there's a group
of uh methanotrophs these are methane
eating microorganisms that were really
just quite controversial their existence
was quite controversial until just a
short time ago um it was debated whether
or not they even existed um but now we
can see their presence in some systems
where actually they're consuming more
methane than is being produced from that
environment uh we're also seeing huge
Paradigm shifts about where and when
greenhouse gases may be produced uh for
example for a very long time it was
assumed that methane could only be
produced when you were in an oxygen
deprived environment an anoxic
environment we're now seeing that
actually very oxygen rich environments
so a large portion of our planet May
produce methane and so as a
environmental microbiologist we're
finding out that there's still lots to
learn simply about the microbial
inhabitants of these environments and
how they may contribute or mitigate some
of these greenhouse gases contributing
to climate
change David your work's in machine
learning and I I'm sure there are a lot
of people who imagine that there could
be great things that machine learning
and artificial intelligence could bring
to climate change but give us a little
bit of a sense of what's happening in
your
field yeah um thank you for the question
and it's a pleasure to to be part of
this discussion so I think it's worth um
noting that a lot of the machine
learning and AI makes the news isn't
that isn't the the AI That's having an
impact on people's lives either in the
climate space or in in many other spaces
and AI is not some futuristic technology
it's something that's being used across
Society right now um we're seeing the
kinds of work being done in the climate
space including everything
from satellite uh imagery
processing algorithms being used by the
UN to pinpoint where floods are
happening and and intervene to
forecasting algorithms being used to uh
reduce energy waste in the electrical
grid um and in terms of of research
breakthroughs that I'm particularly
excited about I'm really looking at ways
to integrate domain specific knowledge
everything from system physics to
information about location where the
data is gathered other kinds of
knowledge which has been gathered uh by
hard one experience across different
domains of application and integrate
that into machine learning because too
often AI machine learning is very data
driven which is great but really
neglects the effect of interdisciplinary
collaboration in driving a new form form
of innovation which incorporates
Knowledge from different domains
together and I would say that that's
actually right at the very heart of
everything that sear does is to build
those interdisciplinary linkages as much
as possible Richard uh tell us a little
bit about your area of work but also in
so doing what are the things that make
it hard to accomplish the work and and
to advance uh research that may help us
address climate change
H well one of the key challenges really
on acting on uh climate change um is an
old one uh and it relates in in part
also to Sarah's work as well you know
will we be able to feed
ourselves uh water resources are
declining in many of the world's most
productive frood growing
regions uh close to me here in the
California Central Valley of the US
Northwest India the North China plane
and with global warming affecting these
rain rainfall patterns um leading to
fewer but heavier rainfalls this
impaires rainfed Agriculture and this is
particularly important in low-income
countries across the C Tropics but it
also incl increases Global Water demand
for irrigation and major questions are
where is this water going to come from
and how what are with uh these changes
in our rainfall patterns um uh how we're
going to need to store more water and
also we have the risks of contamin
associated with that and so there are
major challenges that we uh that I find
in terms of the the uh the research
activity um is uh taking if you want to
call it innovations that are arising
from um of research and getting them
into practice and those are the that
that really uh the research into
practice is really the one of the major
challenges uh in doing that
effectively thanks very much Richard you
mentioned Sarah's work and I'll come to
to you Sarah right now uh tell us some
of the challenges that you face in in
your interest in food and and fungi in
in actually making the kind of progress
that we
need yes so thank you very much uh
Rich's comments really have just
highlighted the strength of sear in
catalyzing collaboration between really
disperate subjects so for me funi are
absolutely beguiling and also rather
horrifying because they are really the
most important agents of crop disease
when you think about the calories that
we eat which is rice and wheat and Ma
and potatoes and soybean being the top
five ones each of those is challenged by
a different fungal disease what we can
see sadly since the Inception of the
Green Revolution is that we're planting
great monocultures I think the the
largest field is actually a wheat field
in Alberta which is 14,000 hectares in
size where we've planted genetically
uniform wheat guarded by one inbred
resistance Gene and sprayed by
antifungals so what happens is the
pathogen nimbly adapts itself to become
almost it sees itself as having a
pleasurable feeding and breeding ground
and it literally goes quite mad eating
through its its vulnerable crops
unfortunately what we can also see is
that fungi are very Nimble in terms of
how plastic they are so they can fast
forward evolution in terms of becoming
not only resilient against the crops but
they can adapt to temperature so they're
temperature adapting and also sadly
they're also adapting to moisture
meaning that they can perceive if you
like dramatic weather so not only have
we got temperature rise problems but
we've also got the incidence of dramatic
weather leading to adaptations in the
fungal genome so what can we do about it
well I think the most important thing is
firstly to raise awareness and I think
if you went out into the streets in
Toronto and did a survey of a thousand
people and asked them about disease
everyone would come up with a human
disease like malaria or covid or HIV I
don't think one in a thousand would even
think about the implication of fungal
diseases on crops compromising our
calories so it's a really extraordinary
thing that we have to do to raise
awareness of the plight of plants to
fungal
disease so we've got a sense both of
raising awareness of where the risks are
and also a sense that turning our
research results into practice is a
fundamental challenge but there's also
this challenge that a couple of you have
noted already of of transforming what we
know into policy that can actually move
us in the right sorts of directions and
I mentioned a couple of times we've
mentioned that cop 28 is taking place in
just a few days and I'm curious um and
and I'll come to both Jackie and David
on this one
do either of you feel hopeful that the
researchers and policy makers world
leaders who are coming together at cop
will actually be able to address climate
change in effective ways in the shorter
term David why don't I start with
you I'm not especially
hopeful
um
but where I do take
hope is in remember that climate change
is not an onoff
switch every bit of work that we do
every bit of progress that we make is
having an impact on people's lives many
people have died as a result of climate
change already and millions more will
die regardless of what we do but we get
to choose how many millions that is and
I am hopeful that there will be some
progress achieved at the cop and more
broadly in the policy space because we
have been seeing that will it be enough
to steer us towards the best or even one
of the better Pathways
um for the global
climate that remains to be seen um and
the role of probably all of our work um
is in making some of those lines for
Action easier not in replacing policy
which is necessary fundamentally
necessary but in making policy actions
easier increasing the knowledge that the
people have and decreasing barriers to
action but there are still barriers to
action Society needs to make various
choices those are hard choices and we're
making some of them slowly and
imperfectly not enough not fast enough
but whatever we do counts and whatever
everybody does counts we really need all
hands on deck
here thanks uh Jackie anything you you'd
like to add to that yeah I feel exactly
the same way as as David I maybe have a
bit more of a an optimistic
lens um but I think that's because I
choose to focus on some of these
imperfectly uh implemented um you know
moments of progress that we're seeing
and I'm seeing these moments of progress
more and more and that's what's giving
me a lot of Hope is there it's getting
increasingly easier to see progress to
hear those good climate action stories
and I think that that is in part because
it's um more prevalent in the social
narrative uh it's very common to hear
about climate change at the dinner table
um whereas before it was almost you know
scientists screaming into a void but
that void is now a lot of citizens who
are writing their MPS who are insisting
that their
politicians uh try to take action um and
and I I agree that it's not it's not
perfect um but I do see those moments of
Hope and I do think that we have the
potential to increase that momentum and
and I'm hopeful that we can we can do
that as a human species thanks and I I I
want to go back into a p the perception
of of risk uh in climate change which
we've already uh we've already begun to
address but if we want to be explicit
about it we have threats to human health
we have threats to Wildlife to various
ecosystems to food uh really every
aspect of life on the planet including
human life can be affected by climate
change and so every now and then of
course that makes it seem overwhelming
and it also means that setting
priorities can be a bit difficult here
uh especially research priorities I I'm
curious Sarah how do you think research
could actually
help set public priorities and and how
can we try to ensure that people are
really working to move in the same
direction or to push in the same
direction well I speak with complete
bias and perhaps a little UK Centric at
this point but my my motivation now is
having written some a plethora of
different papers about this topic is to
push from science into translation into
policy and I'm really happy that the UK
government or the English government not
yet the Scottish government have
embraced Gene editing so suddenly we're
beginning to get an understanding about
if we make climate smart plants we might
be able to make them more resilient to
agriculture so what we need now to do is
to roll this out on the world's stage so
not only as climate smart plants but
also raising awareness of the plight of
plants as I've said before to different
diseases so we're very good in the
medical world and huge amounts of
publicity as we've seen over for the
tragedy of covid but what we don't know
enough about is the impact of diseases
on our crops so I think for us in Sea I
think we have to shout with one voice as
loud as we can about education across
all scales of Ages right from primary
schools through universities up to us
older folk making a huge noise if we can
politically so absolutely there seems to
be the a shared I think impetus from all
of you that we have to be louder we have
to be coordinated we have to take our
research and and get it out into the
world Richard do you think research has
the capacity to Short Circuit slow
moving policy uh and political
environments uh we we do you're right
Jackie there are you know conversations
over the dinner table but at the same
time when you look at polling data a lot
of it is starting to show that strangely
climate change is falling back on the
political agenda in comparison to
worries around uh cost of living worries
around job losses Etc so Richard I'm
just curious how do you think research
can help us make sure that climate
change uh remains in the Forefront of
our
thinking well maybe taking it out of the
hands of the politician slightly um so I
think uh uh what we're seeing now is
there's an increased Trend if you will
to more um uh participatory research we
we know there's um uh uh the the
expression is citizen science that
people are using at at times there's
also this trend towards um a
transdisciplinary research so that's
research that directly involves user
Comm communities in its conception and
in its
implementation and I think that these
approaches research that um that kind of
transdisciplinary research has the
capacity to inform change LED by people
not necessarily by uh politicians and I
think if you look over uh over our past
it's really ordinary people showing what
is possible that is responsible for much
of the progress we see in our society so
of course we're going to need a an
enabling environment that's provided by
policy and politicians and that's that's
kind of essential to sustain the change
but maybe what you're talking about
raising awareness um uh maybe we can do
that with re with uh research teams
working more directly with user
communities and and in essence showing
up the politicians for a lack of
leadership on this and I and I I just
think that perhaps um uh it's
researchers coming together with the
user communities as one way to that
maybe one way um uh uh to do this um uh
you know sadly the political motivation
and policy environment uh often follow
rather than lead on these and um and
certainly I mean the cop 20 uh the cop
process that we've are observing uh is
reflecting this I I I was at cop 27 last
year and I found uh and and I really
found that the public voices outside of
the cop were more Progressive and more
advanced than the discussion going on um
uh and I and I have a I have a very
vivid memory of sitting in a session in
the American Pavilion where there is
this uh indigenous speaker he was a
hereditary Chief from um uh from
indigenous people of the Amazon is Chief
ninoa and he was speaking and his
Arguments for nurturing a more resilient
Earth were very direct very
clear but I felt very few people in the
room were
listening that's worrisome Jack anything
you'd want to add on that ways in which
research could actually better direct
and inform both politics and public
policy yeah I really agree with with
what Richard is saying um and you know
Community Driven working with
communities working with indigenous
Partners in Canada um in particular is
is something that we're seen more and
more of um but there's also I think a
greater ability for scientist to speak
directly through social media um through
panels such as this one to very broad
groups of people um and in some ways we
don't need to you know write write a
white report that then gets submitted to
a politician who maybe read it um we can
give our results directly to communities
if we're good at translating that
information um and as as Richard said a
lot of change throughout human history
is being driven by Reg people by groups
of people and and empowering and
educating as Sarah says I think has a
has a lot to do with
that I I'd like to switch gears a little
bit and encourage each of you to be able
to dig deeper into your own work and
share as you say some of those results
uh Jackie I'll start with you David
because I don't have to tell anyone that
AI is a pretty hot topic these days not
always for the best of reasons and
there's some really rather strange ideas
that I think have evolved about what AI
can do or should do or should not do but
it does seem to be the case that machine
learning and AI more broadly might
enable us to accelerate breakthroughs in
key areas of research including in
climate change so could you tell us a
little bit David about ways in which
rapid advances in AI might actually
enable us to move more
quickly absolutely and maybe just to
make sure we're all on the same page
here let me quickly Define ai ai is
according to the official oecd
definition any computer approach or
algorithm that makes predictions or
recommendations Etc on the basis of a
defined set of objectives you'll notice
this is not referring specifically to
most of the very specific and uh well
covered AI approaches which are in the
news and around the dinner table right
now and in fact algorithms like
GPT are not really relevant to they're
not relevant to my own work at all and
we're not really seeing them making
positive impacts on the climate at least
not specifically there are broader
effects on Society many negative some
positive which will impact the climate
and we can talk about that later but
really we should think of a lot of the
AI That's impacting the climate as I
mentioned before
being unflashy algorithms that are
extremely impactful and are quite
powerful but are generally powerful in
doing very specific things so four
themes that we see um are AI helping
distill large unstructured data sets
into useful usable information that
could be for policy makers for other
kinds of
decisions the some examples from my own
group we work extensively in
biodiversity monitoring where we have uh
sensory modalities um and sensor systems
which are in the field and can be used
to gather large amounts of data on
ecosystems on species populations and
then that data can be processed at scale
using AI to provide information to guide
land use decisions to guide conservation
approaches Etc we also work on Forest
monitoring so quantification of carbon
stock understanding how much carbon is
stored in different areas of land and
trees across Canada and the world um the
second uh theme that we see is in um
optimization and control where AI
approaches can be used for example to
control or um provide recommendations
for managing the electrical grid to run
much more efficiently use less energy
and that's something that we've worked
on in our own group as well um we see um
uses for AI and forecasting for example
in predicting crop yield based upon
satellite imetry and past data to
understand where there are going to be
uh potential food insecurities moving
forward extreme weather threatens uh
crop production um and we also see AI
helping in scientific modeling and
Discovery we're working closely for
example with environment and climate
change Canada to um integrate particular
kinds of AI to speed up Canada's climate
and weather models uh where there are
pieces that are just extremely slow
taking months to run even on a
supercomputer and AI can help reduce the
computational uh bandwidth there make
something much more scalable and help
guide uh local interventions um and
decision- making as a result uh we're
also using AI to help speed up discovery
of new materials for uh lowc carbon
energy applications like electroc
catalysts for example for uh synthesis
of electrofuels now it's worth noting
these applications are not somewhere in
the future the vast majority of them are
currently being integrated into
applications or being used around the
world to increasingly powerful effect
this is not something that I'm talking
about AI might help in most cases AI is
already helping it's helping sometimes
in in in smaller ways that need to be
scaled up and there's huge room for
improvement on the computer science side
and in particular on the domain
integration and deployment side but
these are these are the ways that that
we're seeing progress be being made and
continuing to
advance that is uh encouraging David
despite your earlier uh perhaps careful
uh not wishing to be overly optimistic
there there did there seem to be some
really productive areas where AI can be
helpful here thank you for that Sarah
I'm curious has AI had an impact on your
work in in addressing fungal
disease yes I suppose David's given me a
real wakeup call to the fact that I
actually probably do use AI in the
computer predictions that we use to
model the movement of crop pests and
pathogens and also to see where we might
grow our our plants more sensibly to get
our crops or to get our our food stuffs
so I think integrating very large global
data sets has indeed used AI um hither
to we've been stunningly slow at these
these predictions because of the limit
in computer capacity so only a couple of
years ago it took us three weeks of
supercomputer time at the Met Office the
meteorological office here in exitor
just to get a pretty crude model out and
we put hundreds of different parameters
in looking at the movement of fungi in
coner with climate change and with their
crops and we knew we've gone completely
wrong because after three weeks we found
out that we should be planting coconuts
in Russia so we knew that we'd gone
completely wrong in terms of some of the
inputs so I think if it can be speeded
up and indeed if I can speak with David
out with this conversation I think we
could do better
still see we're already producing
transdisciplinary work in live time this
is exciting um Jackie I want to move on
to your work a little bit um there was a
profile uh that was published on Sear's
website recently about your work and we
refer in that to a carbon bomb that
could potentially be Unleashed From The
Underground uh tell us about your
research and how you are helping us to
understand that risk
better yeah so the maybe I'll I'll start
off with just describing permafrost and
that's where this carbon bomb is is
potentially going to be in leashed from
so permafrost is ground that's being
frozen or below Z degrees Celsius for at
minimum two years but typically it's
hundreds to thousands of years and it is
about 27% of the terrestrial surface of
of our planet where 50% of Canada so a
large portion of Canada is underl by
permafrost and that permafrost is
storing 1,700 petagrams of carbon and so
that's the equivalent of all of the
carbon in terrestrial vegetation
currently so all of the plant matter is
the equivalent carbon is locked away in
permafrost um there's concern that as
this permafrost is thawing for the first
time in many thousands of years that
that carbon is going to become new
available for microorganisms that are
also in these soils to metabolize and to
to or to eat um as a byproduct of
microorganisms um metabolism or what
they're what they're munching on is
potentially greenhouse gases such as
carbon dioxide and methane uh and of
course those greenhouse gases that would
potentially get released would further
warm the climate which would further
cause more melting of permafrost or th
of permafrost which would just kind of
create this positive feedback loop uh
which once you reach a Tipping Point
would just potentially unleash all of
this carbon all at once um and it's it's
very hard to mitigate the actions of of
microorganisms it's you can't really
tell them to to stop that uh what what
my research is doing is is really just
trying to do some fundamental ecology on
these
microorganisms uh when do they produce
these greenhouse gases or when might
they eat some of these greenhouse gases
because they also have the potential to
use methane as a food source or use
carbon dioxide as the food source and we
see some places in the Canadian Arctic
where we have a net methane snc which is
to say that these microorganisms are
consuming uh atmospheric levels of
methane so even if there's no methane
being produced they can actually
sequester it from the atmosphere so our
work is really trying to understand the
the when and the where and the who in
terms of the microorganisms a bit better
and and this directly you know would Rel
relate to carbon budgets um we think so
if we can't fully understand the natural
emissions how can we really budget how
much we have to offset our carbon if
we're if we're not accounting for it so
it becomes a potential contributor to
accounting carbon
accounting and just to go back to the AI
question then for you presumably you are
dealing with huge data sets that are
that would have Global uh inputs are you
directly using machine learning in your
work or are you relying on others to do
the number crunching if I may put it
that way uh we I am my I'm not using uh
AI in particular although maybe like
Sarah I'm realizing I may be using a
machine learning more than I I realized
I do use
models um but I would say right now
we're actually really limited with boots
on the ground data uh a lot of the
literature just calls permafrost
permafrost because it's defined by
temperature uh but of course permafrost
much like soil in my backyard versus
Sarah's backyard or Richard's backyard
have different properties they have
different geologic histories different
carbon content and we need a lot more
data about these different types of
permafrost that we as a scientific
Community simply don't have yet
fascinating Richard your work goes in a
really quite different direction in that
your as I understand it work is about
harnessing the output of climate change
specifically heavy rainfall in order to
address climate inequalities in
Equatorial Tropics so it seems to me
you've got quite a unique perspective on
how severe rainfall events can be both a
blessing and a curse so tell us more
about that
please yeah so the the field research
that I have conducted with uh research
institutions in tropical Africa and
South Asia um it shows that groundwater
is replenished primarily by heavy
rainfalls and the intergovermental panel
on climate change defines those as
greater than 10 millimeters per day and
so the widespread transition that we are
seeing towards fewer but heavier
rainfalls and that's a direct
consequence of global
warming increases the renewability of
groundwater in many environments and
especially in the tropics where this
amplification of climate or rainfall or
precipitation extremes are most
pronounced
so I often get this when I give talks on
on this so you you think climate change
is a good thing no um uh look Associated
increases in the frequency and duration
of droughts The increased frequency and
intensity of floods these are all wholly
undesirable uh consequences and can be
terrifically uh destructive
but um you know it's basically trying to
draw upon the reality is it's happening
and now how what do you do how do you
respond to that and understanding how
global warming affects water balances is
vital and uh and uh and the idea that we
are um we can see that the um
understanding yeah understanding how
these water balances change in response
to warming is really is really
fundamental and it's particularly
important in drylands and in tropical
drylands where uh many of the world's uh
lowest income countries
reside and in these environments um
groundwater uh is often the only
perennial or year round source of water
so the idea that this shift towards
fewer but heavier rainfalls may actually
amp or U increase the renewability of of
groundwater is uh is fundamentally
important
yeah Sarah uh people are talking a lot
about pathogens in our world but they're
often talking about viral pathogens your
work is in fungal pathogens which is
also having a bit of a moment because of
television programs such as the last of
us about a a fungal disease that creates
zombies uh that's not your work I know
that but there is a real issue around
the spread of path of fungal disease uh
having potentially Global impact you've
already given us a little hint of the
work that you do but tell us more about
what you think are both the threats and
potential opportunities that funi
present okay so let's start with good
things about fungi so however Bleak and
however Grim this story The Last of Us
is or was at least it raised awareness
about fungi and nothing is really
completely bad about fungi so we can
also I guess naively call them our
friends because without fungi we
wouldn't have Beal laac time antibiotics
citric acid immunosuppressants statins
we wouldn't have our knowledge of the
cell cycle we wouldn't have had three
Nobel prizes awarded to the science of
Bui Etc so there are good things they're
good in BIO remediation and all sorts of
things however they're also the greatest
pathogens of crops as I've said so we
can look at their Movement by what we've
done is something rather unusual so in
the 1900s or so there was this concept
put about called the disease triangle
and the disease triangle concept simply
says that very naively when a host is
susceptible I it doesn't have any
resistance genes in the crop for example
the pathogen is abundant and virent and
the climate conditions are right for the
growth of the pathogen then you get
disease
so what we've done perhaps rather
naively is we've parameterized each of
these nodes in a temporal sense too so
we can now project forwards to look at
the movement of these crop pests and
pathogens and in so doing we've been
able to do it at the global scale as
well as a landscape scale and with
individual diseases so for example the
greatest pathogen of rice is a fungus
called magnor rice blast disease and
considering that Rice feeds half the
world's population what we can now do is
predict where this pathogen will be not
only as the crop moves but also in
concept with climate change so we're
beginning to raise awareness so that we
can then instigate crop protection uh
strategies and inform governments about
where they might predict new diseases
will occur and this has had an impact in
India in China and in Madagascar where
actually Madagascar are thinking quite
seriously about planting yams rather
than growing rice because of the threat
of disease so suddenly the science is
beginning to be translational enough to
affect
policy fascinating I want to connect um
the work of Richard and Sarah around the
question of food security if I may um
obviously both uh depletion of
groundwater fungal pathogens could be
major threats to food security globally
uh and there's no doubt that they're
being exacerbated by climate change
how you both referred and especially
Richard to interdisciplinary or you use
the term transdisciplinary collaboration
say a little bit more about the ways in
which working across disciplines can
help us address these complex issues
Richard I I'll start with you and then
I'll come to back to you
Sarah
um well addressing I mean what uh the
transdisciplinary work is um and when we
when we use that term we're talking
about not only interdisciplinary science
but also the participation of the uh
stakeholder communities that um
obviously would use uh this
information and um uh the work that I do
um uh the science of the if you want to
call it the hydrological science is just
one part and uh that's not necessarily
going to affect change we have issues
around Equity of access Equity is a huge
Challenge and understanding how in a uh
specific context we are not continuing
to disadvantage if you will poor
communities so for instance depending on
their uh uh the environment in which uh
they are living in whether the um if you
want to call it ensuring that adaptation
to climate change um uh is not actually
making their situation worse while we
are privileging perhaps people who are
coming from wealthier communities in
fact I see this even in in the in the
cop processes where um we talk about um
loss and damage and how do how do we
compensate lower income countries who
are you know in a kind of climate
Justice uh uh perspective and we talk
about funds and they're thinking about
funds for
investors so when you have that image
that um uh uh that funding is going to
be is going to actually Target those
poor less well uh communities and you
know you could imagine a kind of classic
framing of of seven living in coastal
Bangladesh this is not the way that
climate Finance is working at the moment
so the the the if you want to call it
the we have to kind of move beyond our
individual scient if we're going to
inform policy effectively we have to
move beyond our individual science so
I'm I'm primarily a physical scientist
working in hydrogeology and hyd and
hydrology but I work very close ly with
people who look at the political
dimensions of this say transboundary
aquifers and transboundary um uh river
basins and also people who are uh uh
experts in understanding the equity of
any of the um uh uh of any uh proposed
Solutions uh uh to this and so it's
really fundamental that you have um uh
all sides uh participating in in this
kind of work otherwise you you uh you
may lead to what are maladaption I guess
is the word that people are using most
frequently for this so um uh yes I I'll
I'll I'll end there thank you Richard
Sarah examples of where you think
collaboration across disciplines really
makes a difference in your work oh so
for me it's the pure joy of realizing
that I can ask a relatively naive
question and someone can help me with
sums that are Way Beyond My Brain
so for example I can say I have got all
this data it's dirty can you help me
clean it up then can we do something
naive can we rank the order of
importance of the different factors so
it will be like me taking a handful of
sand and throwing it into the air and
saying could you please model in
n-dimensional Space the relationship
between the individual grains of sand
each being a data point and I've been
delighted that the mathematicians in
Oxford and also my colleagues in exor
have said yes we can do that and then
they've grown in confidence and suddenly
we've got transdisciplinary discussions
where we're talking to and at each other
understanding perhaps 50% of what we see
but seeing 100% of the implication of
the outcome and it's truly exciting
that's great uh we have quite a few
questions coming in from uh people
online so let me get to some of those
right now and there's a cluster of
questions that's building on I think
Richard's earlier comment about this
difficulty of moving from uh one's
Research into practical impact and uh
one person has asked a more pointed
question uh which is as this person sees
it a rift between Academia and the R&D
sector in
Industry uh and the assertion is that
government is trying to bridge that acts
in the middle uh and the says that to
him or her the alignment of these
stakeholders that's Academia industry
and government is one of the greatest
challenges in climate change I'm curious
uh any of you have observations about a
do you agree that there is this Rift
between Academia and a and Industry and
how might we Bridge it uh I'm gonna come
back to you to start Sarah because I
think probably in your field there may
have been some conversations around this
yes so I think it's very topic dependent
and I think that all research should be
for public good but of course our
careers are launched on what we publish
and I think as I've gone through the
system it's become more and more open
and more collaborative however it wasn't
always so and I think that many of us
started our careers quite siloed my
experience also of industry is very
topic dependent so for example almost
all the fungicide Discovery at the
moment is done by large agrochemicals
compan comp and it really is data which
is held out with the public domain and
everything is for profit now I think
that we need a very large Global
initiative that says no we have to
protect our crops better and we have to
make everything free at source for
everybody and that simply isn't
happening
unfortunately David you commented
earlier about uh you know some of the
difficulties of translation of work into
policy I'm C ious have have you felt
this disconnect between your work and
Industry and is it something that you
see possibilities for
bridging yes absolutely and um it's
something that I work closely uh a space
that I work closely in because I also
um co-founded and co-lead uh nonprofit
called climate change AI that works on
really facilitating the
research through deployment pipeline for
AI uh in climate
change
the there are many different challenges
here um and one of the biggest ones that
maybe doesn't get properly recognized is
that there is a lack
of trying to achieve the same thing
sometimes
um between different
stakeholders um and it is important to
recognize for example if you are an AI
person wanting to work on climate change
that you're going to have to abandon
some of the traditional metrics for
evaluation of success that you may be
used to you're going to have to abandon
some of the traditional data sets even
some of the traditional methods the way
in which the the culture of AI is set up
is such that it's designed to promote
innovation in ways that are easily
quantifiable and that are easily
interconvertible across
different uh kinds of problems and
that's just not the way that the world
Works often you have to spend a while
sitting down with the relevant
stakeholders understanding what metrics
for Success they have the metrics for
Success may be reliability across
different kinds of regimes and the
notion of reliability that they have may
be different from the notion of
reliability ility and robustness that
you have in AI they may be in interested
in working across different Geographic
regimes in extremely low data settings
those may be regimes that you are used
to in one in very stereotyped contexts
but not in the field and there are new
challenges which occur in the field and
so these are some of the challenges
which we see in the EMB bridging this
Gap this is one of many challenges we
need to have more incub ation of
projects that bring together different
stakeholders so that they understand the
relevant challenges and aren't working
to solve the wrong problem we have so
much there is so much that needs to be
done but on the other hand the desire to
help can easily be diverted into
something that sounds good but isn't
actually solving problems that people
really
need thank you uh Jackie a related
question uh but perhaps a bit broader uh
in your work you're obviously producing
information that could have a big impact
on how we address climate change from
the perspective of these organisms
existing within the permafrost do you
feel that there are big barriers in
getting that information out getting the
data out getting the learning that you
are creating in your research into
places where it can be actioned if I may
put it that way what are the barriers
for you if any yeah that's that's a
really good question and if you if I had
been asked that question a year ago my
answer probably would have been
different um a year ago I would have
probably said well I do an experiment I
make a measurement I publish a paper and
therefore it's out there and hopefully
the right you know the right stakeholder
will uptake it um which is not a great
way to get that information out there at
all
uh and so you know I think in terms of
the barriers it's the knowing who those
stakeholders are identifying them uh and
making sure that you're actually
communicating with them uh I work now
with uh government partners with the the
Geological Survey of Canada and
environmental and climate change Canada
for example um different indigenous
Partners who who have a great interest
in in our findings as well um and so
having talks with those stakeholders and
presenting that work and those results
in a language that is easier to digest
you know we I think scientists often get
really you know in the nitty-gritty
details and and the semantics but it it
actually acts as a barrier for the
uptake of some of that information um
which may not be as important for some
of your stakeholders um and so I think I
think for me as as an early career um
researcher my my earlier barriers were
just trying to figure out the who how do
you get that information out there
effectively and actually this is
something that cifar really helped me
with and and identifying stakeholders
and putting me in the room with some of
these stakeholders as well to get to
talk to them directly it's a major Focus
for a new strategy for sear to uh try to
address that that whole question of how
to facilitate impact more directly um a
completely different question um which
is really about education and education
at earlier stages the the the person
who's asking this question is concerned
that we may not be providing the right
skill sets for for children as they go
through Elementary and secondary school
or primary and secondary school uh to
set them up to be addressing the kinds
of issues that they are going to face um
this is a tough question I'm going to go
to you Sarah do you have any thoughts on
whether our education system broadly is
uh setting us up for success in
addressing these kind of tough
challenges like climate change so for me
I think the most important thing is to
endow a child with enough confidence to
stand up and speak and that's not
something we're doing particularly well
as as they're so busy with their all
their computers etc the other thing I
feel very passionately about is the lack
of plant biology in the curriculum so
everything can be storytelling we only
have to think about the tragedy of the
Irish Potato Famine and the fact that it
infected Canada dramatically was a milon
people starved due to the potato disease
and a million immigrated to the new
world not East to Canada so I think it's
to do with storytelling and in in doing
in in uh giving these the Young Folks
huge confidence to stand up and speak
with a passion about something that's
interesting I'm sure we could have a
whole panel on this subject but
unfortunately we we are starting to run
out of time and I want to ask each of
you one final question uh which is
really just for you to identify
one small or large action that you think
um you can take in your work that really
advances our ability to address climate
change what's what's the what's the
thing that gives you a sense of of
purpose if I may put it that way in the
work that you're undertaking I'll start
with you uh
Richard um what gives me a sense of
purpose really is that um uh is
realizing uh um or identifying and
realizing Solutions and doing that in a
in a in a in a Cooperative way and um at
the beginning of of my career um and
getting back to a bit to the educational
Point uh point of view I mean
groundwater doesn't feature in a in a
curriculum I have first year students
that come to University and groundwater
has almost n been mentioned in their
education to that date and yet you know
it's fundamentally important to not only
our Water Supplies but our food supply
and so what I feel what I get excited
about is uh uh working uh working with
call uh with colleagues and and finding
that uh the role that groundwater can
play in helping to moderate the impacts
or adapt to the impacts of climate
change and we've had some real successes
in uh in enabling uh uh uh sustaining
food production and enabling uh uh or
maintaining and sustaining access to uh
uh to safe water supplies and uh and
that is terribly fulfilling um uh at the
same time I'm very nervous that we don't
recognize particularly the climate
Injustice meaning the fact that people
in uh uh in in low-income countries
across the tropics and even in the high
Arctic are really disproportionately
impacted uh uh by climate change and
here I am in California people in
Toronto and other locations think ah
well maybe it's not such a big deal well
it's a bigger deal further away from
where you are and that our our own um uh
uh our own emissions uh are you know are
having that impact far from where we
live so I guess I guess it's realizing
some success in in in adaptations um uh
is is a is is a Big Thrill that's great
and uh the rest of you are now off the
hook because uh we're running out of
time I'm afraid and I want to turn it
back over to Hannah yakobe for uh final
words before we break but let me just
say thank you to each of our panelists
back to you
Hannah well thank you so much Stephen
and thanks very much to our panel this
has been such a lively and fascinating
discussion uh to our audience as well
thank you so much for being here today
and for joining us from five different
continents and so many different time
zones um I welcome you to visit our
website at c.ca to find out more about
this event series and as I've mentioned
before you'll be able to view recording
from today on our website in about a
week in case you'd like to watch it
again or share it with your community uh
finally if you'd like to find out more
about the researchers who participated
today and learn about their work um I
encourage you to visit our website at
c.ca and read the interviews and stories
that we have um with them in our series
called nurturing a resilient Earth thank
you very much take care and until next
time